i've seen it up close and personal too
man like i told you before
uh my brother died when he was a few
months old
and so watching my mom go through that
bro shoot man
i i didn't even know how to process it
you know because how old were you i was
in elementary
yeah and so like just
waking up to uh
hearing like your mom screaming and
crying because
that day when it happened when i woke up
the uh the paramedics were already there
and
i they were like taking out you know
was probably you know my brother's body
like just kind of covered up
and found in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain
podcast i want to start off this podcast
by saying my condolences to chrissy
teigen she
lost her child yeah it's pretty sad
[ __ ] sad
man i can't even imagine i i had on this
podcast uh
an episode a while ago the audio was a
little [ __ ] up i'm gonna have them
come back here again
um but they they have been going through
the
um ivf process for i think seven years
and they couldn't have a kid
yeah the whole time and um i think just
the process i think they did it about
four times and by the way this process
is extremely expensive
but when she was on this podcast she was
talking about how
she asked me like do you is there
anything in life where you feel like
you have one purpose and that's it and
for her is to give birth to a child and
be a mother
that is her purpose in life and for her
it felt like
just because that's her life purpose
that she needs to fulfill yeah that no
no matter what she has to do and what
she shared on this podcast is that
uh when through the i think it was like
through the anesthesia process she
actually died and had a resuscitator
back to life wow and it was a hard part
for
um jeremy her husband where he was just
at a point where he said i don't want to
do this anymore yeah he goes if i have
to lose you
this this whole process isn't worth it
but for her she
wanted to do this yeah she had to and so
they did it one more time
she got pregnant she's actually i think
she's six months pregnant now wow good
for her man
seven and a half years almost eight
years i believe and she's finally
pregnant yeah and so even from that she
started a small
company um called cozy warrior where
it's it's where you wear these socks
that kind of
comforts women going through the ivf
process because i guess a lot like
infertility is something that
affects a lot of women it's not yeah
it's weird because like hood people just
be popping out babies 24 7.
but every time a good human being wants
to like you know what i'm saying like
have a kid it just doesn't happen yeah
but every time like
any of the [ __ ] people back in
sacramento you guys [ __ ] you have a baby
instantly
what the [ __ ] is that about i don't know
man maybe
maybe they're just having a lot more sex
and busting yes dude that [ __ ]
hood is [ __ ] potent as [ __ ]
thug sperm is the [ __ ] maybe no but yeah
like uh
as i started to get older and i had more
and more friends getting married and
trying to have kids
you know really uh opened my eyes to
learning about how common like
miscarriages can be
it's it's it's not something you really
talk about obviously when you're younger
right because it's not your reality at
that moment in life
but yeah it actually surprised me i was
like holy [ __ ]
like there's a good amount of people who
go through that during
uh the trying to conceive a child
process
and i could only imagine man what that
must feel like
you know from from a woman's standpoint
because to carry
a a living human being inside of you
to to nurture that child yeah and and
and uh
look just look forward to the moment
that that child comes into the world
right but to have that taken away from
you
you know whether prematurely or at birth
yeah you know what i mean a friend of
mine was telling me too because she's
uh currently pregnant right now that her
her obgyn was telling her that
miscarriages
do happen and it's something that
shouldn't be considered like
you know it i think as a parent or as a
woman it makes you feel like a failure
like you killed this child
right um but it happens a lot because
the human body like if something is
going wrong during
this process and you have a miscarriage
it's because the body is like oh this
isn't gonna work yeah so your body's
just gonna kill it like a kill switch
yeah and so you'll have a miscarriage so
it's actually your body doing that on
purpose because they know that
there's something's gonna be wrong with
this child um i'm not sure how true that
is but i could be recurrent taking that
information wrong
uh i'm probably not gonna fact check
that you gotta do it yourself
but that's what she was telling me and
that's why like miscarriages too like it
happens a lot yeah and um people just
don't know they think it's just like
you know you just come and sign somebody
and boom you get a perfect baby right no
i just i i
have a friend who just went through a
miscarriage with his wife you know
and like his uh his wife was going
through it man
she was she was devastated because she
was really happy and looking forward to
having a child
so you know it was
i mean just the fact just just the
incident just that incident itself
i can imagine would be devastating uh
for for both people
but even more so for the women again
because she's carried
out it's inside of you man i can't even
begin to imagine what that feels like
dude one of the things that chrissy
teigen said that [ __ ] wrecked me she
goes
she she kind of wrote she put this post
up where she was like
it's weird i'm leaving this hospital
without a kid
right yeah i i saw that tweet that [ __ ]
[ __ ] wrecked me i didn't even think
about that yeah like for this whole nine
months
she was nurturing this child and then
after this whole ordeal is over yeah
she's leaving empty-handed from this
hospital with no kid
right like what the [ __ ] does that feel
like yeah there's nothing there's
you can't even there's no way somebody
can personally describe what that feels
like for you to even get close to
understanding what they're going
yeah and and then you see like some of
the responses
you know like these [ __ ] idiots that
are out i remember i saw what
was saying what no there was like a
response of something about
like these pro-lifers talking about
abortion and stuff like implying that
she got an abortion
or a nine-month abortion [ __ ] that's
not how it works i know but i'm saying
that
like that's the kind of [ __ ] that you
have in this cesspool
of [ __ ] social media man all these
creatures from [ __ ]
cracks in in the earth somewhere
crawling out
and saying idiotic [ __ ] and look man
like i've seen it it could be trolls
yeah they are they could be trolls they
could just be
uh you know really delusional or stupid
people
but i've seen it up close and personal
too man like i told you before
uh my brother died when he was a few
months old
and then so watching my mom go through
that
bro she man
i i didn't even know how to process it
you know because how old were you i was
in elementary
yeah and so like just
waking up to uh
hearing like your mom screaming and
crying because
that day when it happened when i woke up
the uh the paramedics were already there
and
i they were like taking out you know
was probably you know my brother's body
like just kind of covered up
and family and like some neighbors were
there to console my mom too but she was
bro she was spherical he's absolutely
hysterical
and you know what the worst part about
it is it was [ __ ]
new years oh [ __ ] yeah how did your
brother pass away so um he was starting
to have some health issues
and so uh my parents were constantly
going to the doctors
ultimately uh the doctors prescribed
wrong medicine
oh yeah so did you guys sue so
i asked my dad because
they we didn't sue right and and i asked
my dad
why they didn't right and
he said he had his reasons
but he wouldn't really elaborate on it
so i didn't want to probe deeper yeah
but i'm guessing
it was too painful you know to to like
drag that on
yeah after that yeah after losing a
child it was more
something of like i want to forget this
yeah yeah just
i just want to move past this now you
know something because it's not going to
bring your brother back yeah yeah so
i i think i don't know i never got a
clear answer for that so i can't say
uh but that's what i'm assuming because
when he answered it obviously it was on
the table of pursuing a lawsuit
yeah but he decided against it for you
know whatever reason
um so for me too man it was like
you know i think i was like seven eight
years old right
it was really confusing to process
because it's like i had a little brother
that was a living breathing human being
i would like play with him in the crib
and stuff like that do you still
remember all that stuff i do of course
that's nuts yeah of course um and
you know i think even at that age on
some level
at some point like because i remember
one night where
i felt extremely just like
sad and devastated that i don't have a
brother anymore and it just broke me
it just broke me you know and you know i
i went to my mom and she's like what's
wrong and stuff
and basically i told her i was like you
know he's dead
like he's he's gone you know so even at
that age
i understood on some level like the
permanence of that
you know that's super early it is it is
um but again it's not this i'm not
bringing this up
because of me my mom just seeing what
she
went through i could only imagine man
i could only imagine what that must feel
like i wonder like for a woman who goes
through this right
like if it goes on a personal level
where they feel like they're a failure
like they couldn't do what they had to
do to protect this child and
you know there's a lot of stuff like
psychology that goes on sure like it
just
[ __ ] up your mental space you know
because think about it just
just the death alone is gonna put you in
such a dark space
and in such a dark like emotional place
and then on top of that
you have those thoughts starting to
enter your mind when you're already in a
negative space most likely
there's negative thoughts that are
coming into your mind right
how long how long did it take for your
mom to start feeling a little normal
again maybe you remember
it's hard for me to say i i i don't know
your child years ago
yeah yeah i don't know the timeline of
it exactly but
i just remember like the day of um
how hysterical she she was screaming and
crying at the top of her lungs yeah you
know
and i was just trying to process like
what happened what's going on
um the process of death especially at
that young age is very odd like i'd
like i might have said this on the
podcast but when i was at my parents
store i remember
i don't know what happened exactly but
they were cops were chasing somebody
and from what i remember as a kid
i remember that i think that guy drew a
gun or some [ __ ] like that
but cops just unloaded on the duties in
front of my parents store my parents
were redoing the store at the time
because when we first opened up the
store all we had were um
uh cardboard boxes and uh this is when
they were installing the shelves and my
parents brought me over to to the store
because they couldn't i didn't have a
babysitter
yeah so i was just there and i was just
looking through the window and then you
just hear these cop cars go out and this
guy was jetting out running
and they shot the dude there that's the
first time i saw death i think i was
like nine
yeah and i maybe that should affected me
as an adult but i couldn't
process what the [ __ ] was going on it's
hard to it's hard to at that age
because you don't have enough life
experience you don't have context
you know yeah i don't know what yeah the
[ __ ] that was and i don't know if he
died or not but he was dead because
obviously they had
paramedics come and he was definitely
dead like when they look
look back at it now yeah i mean i don't
know what time did to maybe
rearrange those things but i could
almost recreate it in my head like a
[ __ ] movie because it was so
nuts just seeing like this guy jet these
cops get out and just
[ __ ] start unloading this dude yeah
which was so weird you know so i don't
know if he technically had a weapon or
not but maybe i'm just filling in that
gap but i just remember watching
somebody get shot in front of me like
yeah
yeah dude even even like when death
becomes more likely as you get older
right it's it's still always gonna feel
foreign you know because you have this
living breathing person
and then the next moment you don't you
know what i mean it's it's
like even if you know death is
inevitable right
like that's the only guarantee you have
coming into this world
nothing else death is a hundred percent
guaranteed nothing else is
right even if you know that and you
internalize that
when it happens it just it throws you
off balance because it's like
it's so weird you know what i mean yeah
and i was introduced to
to death actually pretty early on in my
life my grandma passed away when she was
55
had a heart attack in her sleep uh i was
maybe like
four years old three years old but i
remember that day too
exactly i woke up in the morning and
again same kind of situation paramedics
and all that
uh all of them were there they were
carrying my grandma's body
out and then my dad pushed me back into
the room and closed the door and said
just stay in there for a bit
and then it's like that's the only
memory i have of that incident
but yeah it's it's like really um
really weird thing to not only be
introduced to it that early but then to
like
process it as you get older um
and again even if you are at an age
where you're expecting
death to become a part of your life more
often
i guess it's never gonna be
something you just easily get through
you know what i mean death to me with
that
you know and i only think about this
recently um
obviously because these [ __ ]
sleepless nights like death is one of
those things as a gift and a curse
because and and the reason why i say
that and you know bear with me as i
explain this
it's you when you start to realize how
finite life is
could you imagine if all of us had to
live forever if we had the ability
to live forever right our choices and
the way that we navigate
and move in this world would be way
different because now that we know that
life is finite
there's consequences to the things that
we do absolutely and i feel like if we
didn't
live forever i feel like a lot of people
would definitely be a lot more morally
devout because there's no consequences
of things that they do
when when death becomes a part of the
picture in the motion picture in your
life there's a moment
and if you're really young and you're
listening to this even as i say this
you're not going to really get it
there's going to be a moment where we're
just gonna click and we're go where you
will you'll sit there and you'll go
oh [ __ ] i'm gonna die one day my mom and
dad are gonna die one day
people are gonna just start disappearing
around me like could you imagine from my
grandpa for example my grandpa lived
that he was like 98.
he had no more friends everybody died
before him yeah he was the last one
alive
he was damn near a [ __ ] hundred his
last friend was this guy we used to call
nakshyadashi
because he used to always go swimming
with go fishing yeah playing swimming
fishing fishing with him all the time
right so
um and i didn't know he passed away
until
um i went we buried my grandmother
before him and i
was walking by and i saw a picture of
him at a graveyard i was like
this podcast is brought to you by fiverr
my friends
have you ever needed freelance work that
was reliable but you just couldn't find
it well
that's because you haven't heard of
fiverr 2020 has been a year of
uncertainty so how can your business
plan for the unexpected well guess what
you do that by hiring reliable freelance
work to get stuff done that you can't
get done
fiverr's online marketplace connects
businesses with freelancers offering
hundreds of digital services including
graphic design
copywriting web programming film editing
and a bunch more i've used fiverr for a
whole bunch of stuff like
if i ever need a website stuff to be
done on the fly and i don't have time to
do it or there's certain things that i
don't know how to do i always hit up
fiverr
the pricing is there it's i don't have
to negotiate anything
um there's plans to when it will be
delivered and it's always been delivered
on time and it's just been a really easy
experience for me
finding freelance work so check it out
guys check out fiverr.com and receive 10
off your first order by using my code gb
find all the digital services you need
in one place at fiverr.com code gb again
that's
fiverr.com g
d when the [ __ ] did this guy pass away
yeah
and my dad was like yeah he passed away
like a couple years ago before your
grandma did i was like dude that was my
grandpa's last friend
and then he outlived that guy for
another what seven eight years
so imagine this whole time and i just
it's weird because when i watch people
age and i see them dwindle
and uh i kind of see like the stuff that
they say
right well first of all i'm laughing
right now because my mom is [ __ ] up
so i remember one time my grandpa you
know he's old and that would be acting
up and [ __ ] like that
and he was doing some [ __ ] and my
grandpa was like he goes i gotta get out
of this house i'm going back to l.a my
mom was like
all your friends are dead
that's cold man oh man
i mean it's true when it's cold as [ __ ]
i'm gonna do them like that
my mom was like yo that's [ __ ] up
all your friends are dead what do you
even say to that
how can you even respond to that yeah
so [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you say some [ __ ] ridiculous [ __ ] but
i think my mom too she did she didn't
maybe it was because a part of herself
didn't want to face her own mortality
but there was a point to well my
grandpa's 98 you know he's not
completely all there and he would do
stuff that was
annoying for her right like he would
like open [ __ ] up and try to build [ __ ]
i remember one time i came in and this
full i don't know where he made the [ __ ]
out of
but this full made a trident out of wood
and i'm like
how did you how did you made this why
why was he even building a truck
because he would he we made a tr i [ __ ]
you not i'm talking about poseidon's
trident
the fork and everything out of wood and
first of all i don't even know how he
curved the wood like that and he soaked
it and did some [ __ ] with it which is
amazing he could build anything
and i had looked at him i'm like how did
you where did you get this wood yeah
what are you doing
he goes i have to protect the house i'm
like no you don't
you're like night what the time is like
95 and i'm like what are you gonna do
he goes he goes do you want me to show
you like yeah he
pokes me in my stomach and i just
remember i just
i was like do it again i grabbed it out
of his head and i was like you can't do
anything yeah but i had a moment where
why
why you got to tear them down like that
because i wanted to stop busting [ __ ] in
our house and making
wood weapons out of it this was like
chopping up the piano and [ __ ] i'm like
what the [ __ ] is going on where did you
get this
where does wood come from it's like from
the side of our house
this guy's looking crazy and i looked at
my my and then my brother was explaining
because he was you know he's gonna be a
nurse he goes you know they're getting
older
he goes he doesn't know like he's just
doing stuff that he's used to doing
i'm sure he's having like lapses in his
mind of like when
and where you know to go back to my
[ __ ] [ __ ] up mom
like she i don't think she understood i
think she was dealing with her own
mortality to see somebody dwindle like
that because she's been around where he
was perfectly fine
and for her to see that it's hard for
her so you know i remember my mom
so mad because he was just [ __ ] [ __ ]
up in the house and she was yelling at
him
and take my mom to the side and say hey
you're yelling at somebody who doesn't
understand he goes oh he knows and i got
[ __ ] mad i was like you are old
enough to understand this
i was like if i was let's say you do
this at your
at his age and i'm like this and i'm
yelling at you how does that make me
look
you cannot do that to him he doesn't
know what's going on yeah
you have to look at it differently but
mom's so [ __ ] stubborn he goes he
knows he knows what he's doing and i'm
like
i got sophia i had to talk to her dad
and my dad had to talk to her was like
what are you [ __ ]
like you're the dumb one you're actually
stupid right now like you're getting mad
at somebody who's [ __ ] old and senior
right
you think he shits in the bed because he
wants to what the [ __ ] are you doing
you know my mom is so hot tempered dude
but just
just dealing with the whole the
mortality of it all like thinking about
death is when i started to i think i
think that was really a huge catalyst in
the way i shifted
um how i uh did things in life that was
just one of the first things
yeah right as it should i feel like
because because if you if you're really
internalizing
uh your mortality and and really
respecting the idea
that death is inevitable yet also
understanding that you never
know what your time when your time is
then
that should create some sort of shift in
your perspective on life
like can you confidently say that when
you go to sleep tonight you're going to
wake up tomorrow and live another day
you can't you can't say that for 100
nobody can nobody can say that for 100
so if you really internalize that idea
and really respect
death right there i just i just don't
see any way how that doesn't
create some sort of shift whether small
or major
shift in your perspective on life yeah
and the things you want
out of it i mean people will definitely
choose to ignore it because there's a
it's it's really hard to deal with you
know and i think with
um like i remember with my with my
grandma that was like the first time i
dealt with death in a devastating way
right like i've had friends who
got shot and died but i can rationalize
that saying they were pretty bad people
you know like they put themselves in
these situations right like i remember a
dude
this was like the first time i had to
deal with death is and i
i might look back at it i was very hyper
emotional about something to a person
that wasn't really that great to me
but he was like a homie right like
you're in this like little group and
click and i remember this dude was in
the hospital he got shot up
uh he he actually passed away but i
remember i was just right and i felt
like a weird guilt
because i remember at this time they
never asked me to in that group
specifically never they never asked me
to do anything right
but whatever was going on specifically
and i never really asked
some [ __ ] went down whether he started
it or not but he was like yo we need
everybody to be there i'm not somebody
who did that type of stuff i was just
one of the little homies that was there
yeah and he was like he's like you down
and i remember he asked and i'm like
no like you know i wasn't in i don't
know what the [ __ ] was going on
and then from and he kind of kind of
hugged me he goes well some [ __ ] happens
i mean that's on you
he actually ended up dying wow and i
remember i was at like a
at a christmas party i had to sit with
it and it just
made me feel super guilty like i i
didn't
i wasn't even that close to him
specifically in the group but him
saying that last thing to me [ __ ] me
up of course i mean that's a that's a
pretty
um like that's like almost like
foresight force he was like
foreshadowing
you know in my mind like oh he's he'll
be fine like nothing's gonna happen to
him but that fool got shot up he
actually got
he actually got murdered in his car
uh and his car got dumped somewhere
so whatever was happening with whatever
he did he [ __ ] he did something really
bad to piss somebody off yeah right
and then uh yeah he just disappeared and
he he ended up
he he was he didn't disappear i'm sorry
excuse me his car disappeared and his
car was found in a ditch later on but he
was in the hospital so what i'm i'm
assuming is what happened to him is that
he they got to him first before he could
do anything
so they probably knew where he lived or
whatever or they went into a car ride or
some [ __ ] my memory is fuzzy because i'm
trying to i don't know if i blocked that
[ __ ] out yeah
or something but i can't remember it but
he uh yeah
he got shot and he died in the hospital
and i was kind of like [ __ ] up from
that [ __ ] yeah
i mean yeah look man even if you're not
close to somebody
if you have some sort of relationship
with him i i just don't
see how it won't affect you in some way
you know
also [ __ ] you for saying that last thing
at the end well if i [ __ ] die
he was like that's on you like what the
[ __ ] like you've
never asked me you know what yeah i'm
mad at him
just insane man i remember too i think i
was at my friend's like christmas party
or some [ __ ] or was the thanksgiving
because we do like a yearly thanksgiving
and christmas meetup
and i found out during that time when i
was with those friends
and i just remember sat there and i
started like tearing up because i felt
so
[ __ ] guilty yeah but it's like what
would i have done yeah i would have done
nothing
right right i mean it's just it's just
uh
just sitting with you in an unpleasant
way because
there's that what-ifs in your mind right
like well what if i did something right
i probably would have lived because i
was so fat i would have took all the
bullets
he decided to just put a shot up first
just bounce off of him i know
it's like he was literally asking me to
come use me as a shield yeah yeah
no but yeah look man again death is just
it's it's a it's a crazy thing man and
to to go through it
i mean i think i went through like three
or four deaths uh before i was even 10.
damn yeah super early yeah uh
like even um these uh these youngs that
i had right
were where my uh my dad hired them
to work um at his place um at a store
in south central and they were bangers
and
they were just trying to like kind of
stay out of trouble i guess that's why
they were working and whatever
and they would crash out of pads
sometimes um i'm guessing when there was
like some heat and they just needed to
you know go somewhere else
and so like you know these dudes used to
like play basketball with me and like
just be super friendly and be like a big
like older brother figures right
um yeah one of them uh got caught
slipping in k-town and got shot up you
know
by a rival gang um and i think that that
was like when i was probably eight
nine something like that yeah you know
so it's like
it's a weird [ __ ] thing and and i
think also too going through those
things
hardened me early because it's like
i think it like indirectly teaches you
there's no room for weakness in this
life
you know because anything can happen um
and i think kind of going through
those things that most
people don't go through at that stage in
their life
made me um less emotional you know
uh and and like so always saw it as
from a perspective of like you can't be
weak you know
you gotta always protect yourself and be
on guard you know
um as a result yeah like like i said
before in the podcast i
you know i've been called like a robot
and
emotionless no i feel those things
obviously i'm a [ __ ] human being i
have emotions it's just
how i display those emotions and how i
deal with those emotions is
is different i guess from the average
person yeah but look man
but everybody deals with things
differently right right right some
people guard from their emotions like my
typical thing is i i laugh about damn
near everything i think it's just
because like i didn't really have a
choice
it goes either i can laugh at this or i
can let it [ __ ] me yeah and so
i can find a funny situation in just
about anything
like even when my my uh grandma passed
away i was super close to her
and you know i've talked about in this
podcast of how emotionally traumatizing
that was for me
but i can also remember some of the
funniest [ __ ] moments from that
funeral
like like my mom crying yeah was one of
the most hilarious things that ever
happened
when queen people cry at funerals it's
devastating
i didn't know this yeah you know i
didn't know about the korean grieving
process of screaming
beyond like screaming your [ __ ] heart
out your spirit out and so literally
like we're
we're sitting there and then we're lined
up next to the casket and
we're kind of tearing up and crying and
my mom just goes
oh my name i just started crying
screaming
you know just and that i looked yeah i
started i was trying not to
and it looked like i was crying like
sobbing my eyes out yeah but i was
actually
laughing my ass off because my mom just
collapsed in the floor started rolling
down the stairs
like dog laughing at your mom's face
collect yourself what the [ __ ] are you
doing it's like a korean drama
and there was this other moment too that
i remembered uh during the funeral where
this lady was trying to shake
everybody's hands and then um
she was going up to shake i think my
brother's hand and she slipped and she
tumbled down the stairs oh no
and i just couldn't stop laughing
because i was like
yo this lady's [ __ ] clumsy what's
going on
there was just weird moments i feel like
god in my life likes to
plant humor for me this is like dumb
[ __ ] yeah like for example my uncle
when my grandma was gonna be put into
the ground this guy is the most
inappropriate human being you'll ever
meet in your [ __ ] life there's so
many stories that i don't think i could
tell in this podcast because it just
makes me it makes my family look bad
yeah
but my cousin was there both my cousins
his sons
and so when they were bringing it was
kind of nice it was almost like a sign
from god that this so it was raining in
sacramento the whole week
and it was still raining the day of her
funeral um but when we went to go bury
her
uh literally rain stop and the sun came
out it was [ __ ] beautiful but because
of the rain it caused the mud to kind of
slide and get out of place so
the place that they slotted out in the
ground to put her in was a little [ __ ]
up
so they had to fix it and so my my uncle
over here is trying to create small
talk as these guys as people are crying
trying to
dig this thing out they're sobbing
people are crying their eyes out yeah my
uncle's just like it's a pretty uh
pretty nice day huh and i'm like
looking at him like are you are you
having small talk at a funeral right now
at the top of your lungs
and i remember what he goes so uh yeah
that's a pretty handy tool huh
you said you're strong huh my
cousin his son goes shut the [ __ ] up
because he's so [ __ ] bad yeah yeah
man it's like oh
hey you know and that was uh the son
your grandma's son uh this is um
the her son-in-law so okay so
so it's my combo have some [ __ ]
respect
jesus this guy is so [ __ ]
weird and so i'm looking at this
situation like
why does this have to happen in my
family yeah like and
even the people at the uh the funeral
that are holding everything and you
they're supposed to be very com i'm
sorry for your loss
i remember one guy was laughing because
he's never seen something like this
before a guy trying to create small talk
during a funeral while somebody is
being buried and he's loud right
like that's a pretty handy tool huh yeah
it's a good
day yeah i'm like dog shut the [ __ ]
up what is wrong with you man that's
that's so
terrible man um i got so i got i got to
bring my cousin on here because that's
his dad
like we were talking on the phone for
three hours last week just reminiscing
about
stuff that he did that i completely
forgot about like i remember one time
this dude
he got so mad at my cousin i remember
him chucking a butcher knife at him this
podcast is brought to you by hellofresh
listen for everybody out there that does
not know how to cook delicious meals
because one
you suck in the kitchen two you always
have leftover ingredients that you know
you're not going to use
or three you hate the cleanup well shut
your face you
gotta get hello fresh hello fresh is
america's number one meal kit service
that saves you a trip to the grocery
store
gives you easy to follow recipes and
allows you to make bomb
ass meals that makes you look like a
boss in the kitchen and you might think
well what if they don't have the food
options for me well your psychopath
they got you low calorie vegetarian kid
friendly
meat friendly carb loving whatever it's
all there i've cooked
six different recipes and i haven't
hated a single one
i made the uh the tuscan chicken pasta
with oven roasted tomatoes and a tangy
cream sauce and you would have thought
your boy was rachel gordon ramsay
morimoto bobby flay baby try hello fresh
out today and you will not be
disappointed go to hellofresh.com
80 brain and use code 80 brain to get a
total of 80
off across 5 boxes including free
shipping on your first
box that is an amazing deal so once
again go to hellofresh.com
80 as an 8-0 brain and use code 80 brain
to get a total of 80
off across five boxes including free
shipping on your first
box and he missed them and if you go
into that duplex that we used to live at
because we used to live in this uh
duplex called 10 woods in sacramento's
kind of ghetto
i remember the hatchet mark on the wall
when he
chucked a butcher knife at wow yeah
that's
that's ridiculous i mean like what if
that [ __ ] hit the kid
you know your cousin he did some crazy
[ __ ] dude the one time this phone went
on this
so he would go anytime they had the the
hangukshing one right the korean
newspaper yeah you know
those articles are so ridiculous yeah i
came in one time into the house right
and we were talking about his health
because he's very healthy
he has that thing where he has a lot of
subcutaneous fat where his belly is
large and it's [ __ ]
hard which is terrible it's a huge sign
that you could have stroke heart attack
or whatever and so
i remember i was telling him i was like
hey uncle you need to lose some weight
like you're getting
uh really out of shape he goes doctors
say
it's a hundred percent okay i'm like
you're a [ __ ] lioness yeah you're the
fattest [ __ ] and this is for me a
fat guy you're so [ __ ] fat like you
are lying right he goes
okay a hundred percent okay and i'm like
okay if you guys notice
my kim jong-il is developed off of this
guy this is how he actually talks i'm
like
go get on the scale so we bring the
scale over to him we get it from the
bathroom we would bring it to the living
room
i'm like como we'll get on the scale i
want to see how much you weigh yeah
he goes okay he gets on right he's maybe
five foot three
it's like 185 pounds oh man right
and i'm like dude you're 185 pounds he
goes
i know he gets off the scale i [ __ ]
[ __ ] you not
he takes the keys out of his pocket and
he puts it down
and he gets back on and it says 185
again
he goes i was like hold on a second
what did you think those keys did those
keys weigh 60 pounds you [ __ ]
it was an aha moment that was stuck
what he did that was the moment i lost
all respect from him as a human being
i'm like did you take your keys out of
your pocket
as if it weighs 60 pounds david wait
he goes i know he takes it out
he has so many funny [ __ ] i mean he's
still around right now but he actually
suffered from a stroke because of his
health issues
that we were warning him about yeah so
he's not as goofy as he used to be i
think the stroke kind of changed them
but this fool used to say like some
ridiculous [ __ ] like i remember
he did he used to say this phrase that
used to piss me off because
he would use it for anything if i asked
for something in the house this is what
he would say i'd be like
hey komabu uh where's my keys at hey
open your eyes
jackass but he wouldn't tell me where
the [ __ ] keys are
i'm like where the [ __ ] are the keys
yeah open to your eyes a jackass
all the time this guy just sounds like a
ridiculous guy
he's [ __ ] crazy but you know that
that
makes you really realize though is that
just how dysfunctional most families are
you know for sure you don't have like
this perfect
uh you know group of characters
uh or not there are characters within
families but
you don't just have these perfect cookie
cutter uh you know
family type members it's there's always
a wild card in there you know what i
mean
he's a i mean even my aunt like his his
wife which is my
my dad's mom because we have a history
of short tempers in our family
i've had a lot of anger issues about my
whole life and it definitely stems from
how my parents and my family deals with
their anger like
break [ __ ] for sure [ __ ] up for sure
but i remember one time my my my
kungomo came so her older sister came
from korea
and i didn't know the type of
relationship that they had
because i really never seen her before
but when she came i was like wow she
looks just like my aunt
and i remember the next day i think
uh that she came and she was staying at
my aunt's place and the next day my
older aunt
was staying with us i was like why is
she staying here that she was staying at
cuomo's place
and i i look at my uh i couldn't almost
face
yeah and i see something a circular red
mark on her face so i'm like
what is that from yeah and then uh later
on my cousins come over for dinner
and i see my como her younger sister
with a
scratch mark on her face and i go yo
what happened that my god is cracking up
you would not believe what [ __ ] it
happened i was like what happened i was
like they got into a fight about some
[ __ ]
my aunt bit my other aunt in the face so
that circular mark
was like on
wow so she bit her in the face and so
she was trying to get her off her face
so she was scratching my other heart so
she had a scratch mark across her face
like a wolverine scratch mark that
that's uh that's a little bit more
dysfunctional than usual
i i i have so many stories about my
personal family that's funny now
it was a little traumatizing when i was
younger sure when you're young seeing
that [ __ ] you're like what the [ __ ] is
going on
like why the [ __ ] do you have a red mark
on your face it was like
so [ __ ] up it's because she bit her
that's [ __ ] ridiculous i
i've never heard a story like that with
family members i could tell you
my cousin knows more because my cousins
are 10 years older than me so
there's there's a fat chunk of [ __ ] that
i don't remember yeah but he remembers
really really well because he was older
yeah so like i i have remnants of these
weird memories of like just my family
just dealt with things a lot differently
like specifically
my grandma i was the only kid that got
my ass with
she never she never hit my brother and
never hit my cousin why so she hated me
oh oh yeah that's right you told me yeah
you told me about this
yeah she had it out for you she had it
out for me you know so i didn't know
i wish because he was when i was talking
to my cousin on the phone uh a couple
weeks ago he goes man i wish i would
have told you that when you're younger
that she hated your guts
she thought you were some latchy kid
that your mom upset with some other dude
yeah
you were born and i'm like i remember
that's right [ __ ] like
is that what she was beating my ass all
the time like it's because she [ __ ]
hated my guts
but the weird thing is when i have
thoughts of my grandma they're very warm
even though she beat your ass all the
time you know why it's because she
always made me this ghetto macaroni and
cheese it was craft
the craft macaroni and cheese with
ground beef that shit's [ __ ] fire
that's why you have more memories
because of food
she beat my ass and then she make this
[ __ ] spaghetti i always like
so she always beat me up but she always
made the food i love though maybe a
little
a little bit felt guilty yeah exactly
yeah it's like i'm gonna beat your ass
again but you know
yes to make myself feel a little better
about it right now get this hood mac and
cheese and you'll feel a little better
about it and she knew i loved that [ __ ]
oh that [ __ ] was so good
yo rest in peace grandma i love you so
much
but yeah this i i have some characters
in my family too man but
i feel like it's it's pretty commonplace
uh for
for there to be some sort of
dysfunctional members in in most
people's family you know
that's why the whole idea behind oh it's
that drunk uncle at christmas right
you always have those characters and
it's just like yeah at the time you
might find something that they're doing
offensive but
like you said you look back on it and
it's just like so ridiculous
you know it's so crazy when people don't
have that i understand why they don't
have much
stories about the family because they
were so normal yeah and i feel like my
kids are going to have a way more normal
life than
than i did because i think just just the
whole immigrant story of my parents
trying to navigate what's going on
and just that stress alone just made
them do [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] the immigrant
story is like
such a perfect scenario for all of these
you know crazy incidents to happen you
know
because like you're figuring it out on
the fly you know what i mean and trying
to build a life for yourself
um and again at the time it might not be
so funny
but you look back on it you're like yeah
that [ __ ] was pretty funny
yeah i mean we could get into more
stories let's get into the
genius uh suggestion of the day we could
i could do a 30-hour podcast about
a bunch of family yeah so this
comes from a guy named jesse i'll leave
his last name out
uh he says just a warning ahead of time
i could give you a lot of backstory and
a lot of personal details
uh okay we'll move on he's just kind of
explaining him so he goes hi
exclamation mark my name is jesse and i
saw your post on twitter so i figured
i'd give it a shot and ask for your
advice
you know i've been watching your videos
since i was in middle school and now i'm
23. let's leave that [ __ ] out
uh oddly enough your videos influenced a
lot of things in my life well he was
actually watching me since the beginning
because i've only been up for 10 years
yeah
i was like that's 10 years so he's been
watching me since i
actually uploaded my very first video
that's crazy that's nuts um
uh coming up in october it'll be two
years since i have okay hold on a second
um
on the end of your videos influenced a
lot of things in my life i used to weigh
250 pounds and my
lowest was 195. now i focus on being a
power lifter
uh mainly because of bart not because of
me [ __ ]
he he immediately had to put that in
place no not because of you
you actually lifted weights for the
first time in a year yesterday
and that's just facts so i'll stop the
backstory and get to the point
uh coming up in october it'll be two
years since i've attempted suicide
did not expect that i moved back into my
uh
parents house i left my job and i felt
or i feel like i lost all my friends
probably one of the saddest times i've
ever been in and was the most i felt
alone i almost gave up completely
two years later i have a job i'm settled
with i have more friends supporting more
than ever
plans on moving out soon going to
therapy and i even have my own podcast
with my best friend
um yeah he says you could plug it in
okay well
don't don't do your podcast plug after
you're talking about a suicide attempt
buddy
hell are you doing okay but i still have
these moments of sadness and loneliness
and that hurts a lot
i guess based on your own experiences or
knowledge do you have any ways of
dealing with being alone
i recently ended things with someone i
thought i loved and now i don't really
know if i really did
the relationship started off bad in the
beginning already she was with someone
when we met
and just ended things when we got
together bad sign
i'm trying not to feel alone anymore and
i honestly don't know what to do
any advice you give is great appreciated
and if you do read this one i'm glad you
decided to give out advice to young
people figuring out um
their [ __ ] too you know uh
maybe i've mentioned this too but just
as a starting point
i think when you're when you're really
young and you're what like about 23
right now
i think that sometimes when bad things
happen we always feel like the thing
that we're going through we're the only
people going through it
feeling alone is stuff that you're these
type of feelings you're going to feel
for the rest of your life
it's not unique to your existence and
that's a concept that's really hard
to kind of accept when you're in some
deep [ __ ] right now
right because i i feel alone sometimes
too even
even with somebody i'm with somebody i'm
with my fiance and there are times where
i feel like she won't understand
where i'm coming from or and i'll feel
like these moments where i feel like
nobody is going to understand me it
happens actually
a lot more than i think about it you
know what i'm saying but i think the
biggest difference is is that
i already have it set in my mind whether
i'm doing it on purpose or not that i
know
these feelings are only temporary like
it's it's a very
temporary feeling you know for for you
to feel
sadness and loneliness because it's
something that's going to be constant
throughout your life
there's this weird thing where people
feel like happiness is going to be
promising them 24
[ __ ] seven yeah you know and you're
basing it off of maybe you're even
basing it off of
other people's [ __ ] if because i know
for a fact that this happens because i i
when i first started doing youtube i
remember just
looking through comments and looking
through success of other people and
starting
i started to do a comparison game and
when i started to compare my life to
what other people were putting out
specifically on their instagram because
instagram does a great job of making you
feel that everybody's living their
[ __ ] best life
right and it makes you feel like you
have you're living without because
everybody has something that you don't
right right there's a there's a lot of
things that you can do to help you
compensate with that like why
just having the thought of why do you
feel alone do you feel alone when you're
more on your phone and then you see
other people living a life that you
don't have
do you feel alone because the people
that are around you you say that you
have great friends
but what qualifies them as great friends
do you connect with them on a personal
level
you know it's it's hard to really
process what you're going through
especially because you know you've
already attempted suicide once and now
that you see yourself on the on the
brighter side of things
um i think you have maybe a false
expectation
of what a great life is because you say
well i have everything and there's still
these moments where i feel sadness
and if i were to be honest with you
right now personally i don't know you i
don't know you on a personal level
but you're actually just going through
regular [ __ ] yeah i mean
look it could be regular [ __ ] for sure
um but for me
it would be really starting at the
basics
starting with the basics is one is that
uh mental health hasn't always been so
great for this kid
obviously right yeah so he's been
dealing with yeah and so i i did hear
that he mentioned therapy in there but
first and foremost that should be what's
brought to the forefront to address
is he should definitely be in therapy
sessions
sorting this [ __ ] out because whatever
is causing this feeling of like
self-hate or or like self-worth
being you know super low and lonely
whatever the root causes of those
feelings are and those thoughts are he
needs to address those first
right so i think we start at the basics
there
and then from there as his mental health
starts to improve
he can start to figure out the things
that really fulfill him and and give him
happiness in life and that's a process
like you said
life is a process man you know you can't
you can't be so
short-sighted with things and and you
know the point that you were just making
is that um younger people
tend to think like at that point in life
that's they're the only ones going
through it
but that's that's a feeling and an idea
that comes from
like limited experience with life you
know as you get older and as you
experience more things you start to
understand
it's this is a shared experience man you
know
a lot of the things that people are
going through other people countless
other people have gone through the same
thing
at those points in their life and if you
just reach
out and try to talk with somebody if you
have somebody like that in your life
then chances are you're going to be able
to see that they probably went through
the same thing
now the difference is going through
hardships in life in certain moments of
your life
and also going through those hardships
with your mental health not being good
that's why i say that we should focus on
the basics here is like make sure the
mental health part
is is good first get that solidified and
then from there
you could start figuring it out but if
he's 23 now
i mean he's still so young he's still so
young
and i i maybe my perspective is a lot
different right because i look at trials
and tribulations now
as just like uh a paintbrush with a
different color in my life
right it's just adding like another
color right because imagine if life was
just
everything happened the way that you
wanted it right could you imagine how
boring life would be
right if you didn't have trials and
tribulations if you didn't have
something bad
to show you how great something can be
all the great stuff in life really
wouldn't matter
right because you wouldn't have
perspective yeah there's a very big
difference
like i've i've been in this city now
where i've been around people who
um either was born into born with money
and the people who gained success and
then made money right the the one thing
that i've noticed for people who are
born with money
and i'm not saying this is a truth but
this is the people that i've met people
who grew up with a gratuitous amount of
money and always had the word yes thrown
at them
at this age in life the age of 30 they
don't know what the [ __ ] they
want to do they're lost because they've
always had options
and they almost had a point of they
never had to earn anything right like
in their mind they couldn't think of too
many uh trials and tribulations that
they had to go through so there wasn't
anything that for them to hold on to
but versus people who i know who have
gained a similar amount of success but
they had a struggle through it
they get to relish in their scars and
their battle scars a lot that allows
them to appreciate the things that they
have around them
so if you're looking at these situations
where you're looking at all the bad
stuff and that's the only thing
only thing that you're focused on you
should be really focused about what
comes after this stuff yeah right yeah
because even like how i pick friends i
say
i say i pick friends like i pick out
watermelons and the reason why is
because if you notice
if you guys ever picked out a watermelon
before
people tell you when you look at these
like cartoons right or you look at
an animation or film you look at this
watermelon it's
perfect bright green a bunch of stripes
and because you've seen this
on the screen that that's the one that
you need to pick out you feel like
that's a really good watermelon but what
you'll actually find out is and you'll
hear through watermelon farmers people
who know watermelons really well
which i say are people the ones that are
the best are the ones with a big yellow
sunspot on it and they have a bunch of
scarring from the pollen and when you
pick it up it's actually heavier than it
actually looks
and that's how i that's how i say you
should pick out friends people who are
who have battle scars
who have been through trials and
tribulations but that are still around
they have a lot more to offer than you
think there's a weight to them
they have life experience yeah and those
watermelons that you pick out are
actually the best
you might actually be one of those
watermelons you might be that person
i have always had the relationship to
food like you might be that
that watermelon with the scars with the
big yellow spot that on the outside
doesn't look very desirable but all that
[ __ ] leads up to something that has
that's very fruitful that you that has
sustenance to it
so like all the stuff that you're going
through right now is going to build up
to a bigger story
you have to realize life is about
chapters absolutely you know absolutely
and it's all about how you write that
[ __ ] yeah
and and again like at 23 you have
limited life experience and limited
perspective
so i could understand i mean i've been
there too so i can understand how
how you might easily fall into this
feeling and idea of like oh my god
this is the worst right it might be the
worst
at that point in time but it might not
be the worst
five years from now 10 years from now
you might look back at that and think oh
[ __ ] that was cake actually
you know now the responsibilities i have
and you know the problems that i have
now are much
far greater and far more serious than
what that was
that's not to take away from how real it
feels at that moment
either uh what i'm saying is that not to
look at it
so uh from like so short-sightedly
uh just think about it from a standpoint
of you're at a moment in your life
and whether whether it's something
that's uh really difficult to
get through or something that you feel
like nobody else can relate to
that's not gonna be the case forever and
and it's like
look you don't know if tomorrow is
promised to you
but on the bright side if it isn't
promised to you
at least you won't know it
yeah if you die you die that's it right
um
but if you're looking forward to the
next day
the next week the next month next year
whatever
then address the problems tackle it head
on first
and it seems like with this guy you know
especially considering the fact that he
tried to commit suicide
mental health is is you know a glaring
issue for him and so
hopefully he can get um the treatment
for it and and continue with therapy and
be vigilant about therapy
not just something where i like
i hope it's not one of those things
where he does it
um here and there and then start when he
starts to feel like things are a little
bit better he feels like he doesn't need
it anymore
and therapy too if you guys have never
done it before therapy is very unique in
the sense of
therapy is like finding a church like
it's not a one size fits all right
right you need to find somebody that
that you can truly open up to and you
have to be mentally ready
for therapy it's not it's not like advil
where you have a headache you pop that
[ __ ] in and then a couple hours things
go away
you actually have to figure out like
what
the reason why you're there and you have
to be open enough to listen
so you know some people that i know that
have gone through therapy they go in and
they go well i did one session and
nothing happened
it's not a it's not that's not how it
works yeah right it's like how much did
you
open up in that session are you
comfortable with opening up to this
specific therapist do you need to try
another therapist
right you know it's just like any other
relationship anything yeah
yeah yeah you really have to look at it
from that standpoint i feel like in
order to
get something out of that um if it's
just one of those things where you're
just going through the motion
you're not going to have any
breakthroughs you're not going to have
any progress with it
it's just going to be one of those
things where yeah you just uh
basically think doing what you think you
should be doing because imagine too i i
had a
i had a young lady named um uh
she she has this company called cat
suites and with her
she she actually attempted to commit
suicide and she was very open about it
and she was kind of helping me go
through the thought process i never
tried to commit suicide before i never
really had the thought about it
so for her you know or when i see that
type of stuff but i feel
when people try to attempt to take their
life what seems to be the reoccurring
story is that
you know it seems to be like a whirlwind
of these thoughts right
and then because everything seems so
definite
there there's no light at the end of
that tunnel so it's
you know that that reason for living is
completely gone
right but what happens in her case too
when i see it right
so she attempted to commit suicide and
it just didn't work out the way that it
was supposed to
uh she survived it and then that feeling
of
sadness and death might come back but at
that moment when she survived it went
away
but that just goes to show how it's
temporary
you know when you when you you can find
comfort in the fact that these feelings
are temporary it's not going to last
and if if you're looking at that as a
perspective of why live when you know
that you're going to go through this for
the rest of your life
i think your perspective is off your
perspective is off because you're
expecting things to always be
great and nobody's life is like that
there should be comfort in the fact that
everybody is going through the same
stuff that you're going through right
it's just a matter of how you're going
to deal with it and maybe finding the
right people to be around you
maybe you do have friends but maybe
they're not the right support group for
you yeah
you know yeah and i think um also too
it's really important to find
the the reasons to live rather than
looking at the reasons to die
oh for sure um and and maybe maybe try
the scott meal that's six dollars
have you guys had that [ __ ] are
you trying to not commit suicide
have yourself that bacon burger with
that barbecue sauce
that [ __ ] keep you alive baby yeah
and so like maybe even in in being in
those shoes
the a person might say i don't have
enough reasons to live i can't find
reasons to live
i mean then you're gonna have to find it
you know like nobody's can nobody is
gonna be able to like instill that will
into you like if you really start to
lose your will
to live i mean that's a really dark spot
to be in
but it's also a limited way of thinking
and a limited viewpoint on life in
general
yeah because you just haven't especially
at 23 you just haven't been through
enough
you have like life from 23
to 30 will look drastically different
you know what i mean when i think when i
was 23 what i was doing and then what
i'm doing at 30
it's like two different people even if
you're considered an adult
yeah at 23 right or i mean 21 and over
um you're not
you haven't really fully come into your
own at that age in life
i feel like uh more so that starts to
happen
you know into your 30s where you really
start to feel like yeah you're getting a
rhythm
you know and and you figure out who you
are as a person and really come into
your own skin
yeah and so look i mean
dark thoughts like that i can relate to
it for sure
um i've i've definitely had moments
where you know uh
i was in a very dark space and uh even
even like the past year
or so you know going through depression
right yeah just
just because circumstances but at the
end of the day it's like
you you have to dig down and find the
strength
uh in order to overcome those thoughts
and and overcome those problems and
overcome those
it is a trial it is a trial it's like ev
and everybody is put through those
trials it's
but if you feel like you know what i
can't handle this
i'm the only person that's going through
it nobody can understand me
then you're limiting yourself it's like
almost a self-fulfilling prophecy
yeah and it's also like this point of
where i feel like sometimes we'll
we're so laser focused into the
negatives in life it's hard to see the
positives right so yeah
we're like oh well i know i'm gonna go
through this again but instead of
thinking oh i know i'm gonna go through
this again
you you like what i was talking about
before where's perspective like i could
say
you could say i'm going to go through
this again or you could say like
this is just a part of life and it's
going to pass the
i know it sounds so overly simplistic
but i'm only telling you
because you're asking for my personal
suggestion or advice that's how i deal
with things
right because i could like for example
we were talking about a story earlier
right where i
saw my i came into the house imagine if
how i painted this story right i told
you that story was on my aunt and she
had this circular
mark on her face where she got bit by a
rabid dog right but what if i told you
in that story where i said like i grew
up in a really [ __ ] up home
like i grew up in a [ __ ] up home where
my where my aunt who i really loved and
cared about she decided that she um
that she grew up in a dysfunctional
family and i used to see them get into
fist fights every day and if and it
[ __ ] me up mentally
look how different that story is yeah i
don't want to hear that story you know
but when i tell you about these two
[ __ ] psychopaths and where this lady
bit this lady like she was a werewolf
i legit thought that my almost gonna
turn to a werewolf like like there's a
way
there's a way that i choose to see life
and it's because i choose to
have a positive outlook and laugh about
things because
like edrick says everybody has a
dysfunctional family
everybody goes through that type of
stuff it's just you know you got to make
you got to make lemonade with your
[ __ ] lemon sometimes man and i think
i do a really good job of that because
i've i quickly learned
that i had to i didn't grow up in a lot
of sometimes when i see other people
complain about their lives it makes me
wonder why um because when i was younger
i would have killed for the life that
they had
[Music]
everybody no matter what situation that
they're in always feels that they're
living without
and i think what's what's uh harder for
this younger generation
um is we've we've said this time and
time again is is the whole social media
factor
right giving giving false expectations
on what life is supposed to be
and and how life should be um we didn't
really have that as much growing up
and then so i feel like uh just kind of
getting down and dirty and figuring out
your problems and just kind of
bulldozing through it was more of our
mentality but then
when you have kind of the comparison
factor of like you're constantly
comparing yourself
to these other people that you see on
instagram and in facebook and twitter
and thinking
that you and your life somehow is
inferior to that
i mean that must be a like a
devastating feeling to think that you're
you're
not your life is not worth as much as
these other people's lives because
what you're seeing and what what you're
what you're seeing them doing
is pales in comparison to what your
everyday life is like
yeah but again social media guys is
not an accurate representation of life
it's not real life
it's it's a [ __ ] highlight reel
please understand that first and
foremost
second again focus on what brings you
happiness
what fulfills you and you know what
there could be somebody who says
look man i don't have anybody to talk to
i don't i don't have
even friends there's porn do you do you
know that there is free porn
at your very sticky fingertips when i
was younger
yo i had to hit up the homie and i had
to i hadn't cut out a piece of [ __ ]
naked titty out of a [ __ ] magazine
with 25 cents a page yeah i used to
slang that [ __ ] bro i used to sling
pages out of the playboy magazine that
was a side hustle for me man
i paid for his college tuition no but
but seriously
like even if you don't have friends
um you can find somebody who's willing
to listen
and i i think it just comes down to how
hard you're trying
it really comes down to will power yeah
i i think like social intelligence is
hard for a lot of people
um it's not really taught and if you
don't see if you're not surrounded with
people who are
who understands how to navigate
themselves through a social situation
you have nothing to learn from
and that's where i feel a lot of people
lack in that skill
is social intelligence they don't know
how to be in a crowd they don't know how
to interact with people yeah and albeit
these people are
good human beings like when you look at
them as a person you're a good person
but when it comes to getting along with
somebody nobody really gives a [ __ ] of
how good a person you are at first
they just want to have a good time for
sure they want to be able to socially
they want you to be able to like
navigate through a conversation there
are those unspoken rules of engagement
right and and when when uh it's not
checking those boxes
it comes across as something being off
or something being awkward or something
being weird
um the point i'm making is that
i feel like if you need someone to
listen there's always somebody
you know and even a therapist right even
if you have to
uh pay a therapist uh to have somebody
to talk to and listen to
that's a great person to to talk to and
have somebody listen to you
because they can help you sort your [ __ ]
out right um
there's always somebody for uh any
there's always
something for somebody yeah right yeah
like that's why i always get shocked
when people say i can't make any friends
i was like
well you're probably a weird [ __ ] but i
guarantee you there's another weird [ __ ]
out there that's just like
you're sure your friend yeah and you two
weird [ __ ] can be together and just be
weird together
but it's it's in um
the effort though how much of an effort
are you putting forth to like
actually seeking a friend or just
somebody to talk to somebody listen to
if you just start you know crumpling up
and thinking oh that that's
too too hard for me you know there's too
much social anxiety
what are you gonna do then right if you
recognize the problems that you need to
face
then face them head on right uh
otherwise that's just gonna be what your
life is and you're getting the larping
guys
what the [ __ ] is larping now you don't
know what larping is no larping is those
guys that
so you know when people play mmorpgs
right well larping is mmorpgs
in real life oh so yeah you'll go out
and they'll like
book out this whole area that's like a
forest yeah you'll go out there
and if you want if i want to attack you
well i have a certain amount of mana
shoot lightning bolts at you so i'll do
this i'll go lightning
lightning bolt okay that's one of those
you could block it you could do it and
then they'll have their whole costume
get up
with their swords yeah hey my friends
i'll tell you if i don't have any
friends
your boy be the number one larper in the
country no you
bringing that up actually reminds me of
a thing too is is that dude with
technology these days you can find
communities
you can find anywhere to find facebook
communities pages
people who have shared interests go out
to those public meetups or whatever
harpers have friends for crying out loud
reddit public meetups i mean there's
many different ways for you to meet
other people
now how well you do once you meet those
people is a different story
but at least put yourself in that situ
you can't sit there and complain about i
don't have friends i don't have anybody
to relate to
and then if you say well what have you
done to try
nothing or i can't because it gives me
too much anxiety
smoke some weed baby yeah whatever you
gotta do whatever you gotta do to figure
that [ __ ] out and look
things like suicide and suicidal
thoughts it's not it doesn't just affect
certain type of people man
we talked about it before guys like
anthony bourdain guys like robin
williams right yeah
these are these are people who are loved
throughout the world
recognized has fame has money has
from the outside looks like just a great
fantastic life
then why did they choose to end their
own you know what i mean because
it's something that affects everybody
it's not just something that only
affects
you know broken people or whatever yeah
it's something that and again it goes
back to that point that we were saying
it affects
everybody everybody's going through some
shade of the problems
that you're going through you just have
to reach out
well first you need to have perspective
that that's not the end of the world
that's not that's not a period in your
life in the
end it's still an open-ended story
i'm a very spiteful human let's say like
in this world where somebody's like well
everybody [ __ ] hates me why do i want
to live well i want to live because
i bother these people so they have to be
with me for the rest of their [ __ ]
miserable lives
just out of spite i'm gonna stay alive
out of spite i'm gonna stay alive
because my existence bothers you
so you hate me that much guess what i'm
i'm gonna lose some weight i'm gonna be
extra healthy
so i could be around for a very long
time and i'll live your dumb ass and
then when you're dead
hey man good life now you're gone baby
turn that negativity into fuel baby and
i'm telling you that [ __ ] dude
there's always a good perspective man
like i figured out you hate my guts i'm
gonna live so [ __ ] long you have no
idea
oh [ __ ] i live so long man i'll
[ __ ] no i i could relate though i i
definitely have those moments too where
it's like
there is kind of like that spite where
like oh
this [ __ ] really want to you
know be on that game huh
then watch me [ __ ] watch me
rather than
letting it help man my feelings are hurt
i don't want to do anything anymore you
know yeah
i'm like all right that just got me the
[ __ ] juice that i needed to get going
you know
i like spiting people man it fills up my
soul very very well
i'm trying not to do that as much i'm
trying to do things out of the purpose
of joy
sometimes man when i see when i see
something like for example when i see
some people make some trash in it as
well
i can do so much just petty bro piece of
[ __ ]
i hope you die but i hope you live god
bless
god bless you pettiness and spitefulness
yes
i'm done you well guys that wraps up
this episode of the genius brain podcast
we know over a lot of stuff we have some
funny family stories and uh if you guys
want to leave some more genius
suggestions or anything
else like that even some weird sexual
desires
whatever [ __ ] that you have out there it
could be a weird story that you guys
want us to hear and sell on the podcast
then we can put our two cents in that's
geniusbrainpodcast gmail.com or if you
guys want first dibs on stories go to
the patreon and
uh go ahead and support out there but
you can find edric at ed2 on instagram
every single handle
ed to edtwo and you can find us
at secretsociety.com
for your clothing needs my friends and
what was the uh the promo code for that
brain 15
brain 15 for 15 off your first order if
you go to
scrt society.com we'll see you guys
every thursday and sundays i'll see
y'all next time love you very much
life is worth living hang in there guys
hang in there like the little cat on the
telephone pole
yeah unless you're a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
it peace
peace